[Musique]
bienvenue sur tv soixante dix huit pour
cette nouvelle édition du 78 tours à la
découverte des yvelines et ce mois ci un
numéro un peu particulier nous allons
nous intéresser à la culture geek
comprenez pour les non initiés à ces
passionnés de cultures de l'imaginaire
au sens large un festival leur est dédié
à les vingt et un 21 et 22 mai aux
clayes-sous-bois le gui cap festival
c'est une première dans la commune
programme complet ambitions de ce
rendez-vous dans quelques instants avec
ses organisateurs culture et geek et le
jeu vidéo un mariage qui va de soi nous
irons à la rencontre du fondateur de
reset xp à montigny le bretonneux
sébastien est ce nous parlera de son
entreprise dédiée au retrogaming et puis
enfin focus sur un petit animal jaune
qui séduit la planète depuis 1996 la
communauté pokémon des yvelines vient de
se réunir il y a quelques jours deux
invités en plateau donc pour débuter
cette émission il s'en charge du geek up
festival aux clayes-sous-bois j'en
parlais il ya un instant ce sera parc de
diane bonjour à gilles guilloux et à
geoffroy cotonnec bonjour à tous les
deux respectivement trésorier et
responsable des exposants sur ce
festival a exactement ce sera une
célébration de la contre culture dans
son ensemble d'abord dessiner des mangas
des comics du médiéval des jeux de
plateau oui mais pas fait de choix c'est
très très large et sa du jeu de rôle du
steampunk du quidditch harry potter du
sabre laser r voilà on tout ce qui
rentre dans le fantastique la pop
culture tout ce qui fait de tous ceux
ont de quoi on est geek on l'a mis on a
inversé c'est très larges concessions
d'indéfini série geek vous d'ailleurs en
fait c'est ça c'est quelqu'un qui aime
son actionnaire c'est un passionné il ya
différents on a différentes en fait
c'est un patchwork en fait on aime ou on
aime pas par exemple on peut aimer du
comique du manga jude rôle du jeu vidéo
un peu gêné mais plusieurs voix là on
peut en numéraire en fait c'est une
passe quand on est passionné de quand on
est un geek entre guillemets je veux
dire c'est qu'on est des passionnés
aussi on cherche un ou des
collectionneurs on cherche la petite
perle rare que personne n'aura et qu'on
est les seuls à avoir et c'est ça qui
est énorme c'est ce passionné par quoi
moi personnellement je suis plus manga
et initie aux comics aussi pour ma part
mon compère ici présents mais yannick
star ac
et dc le a évolué
le quidditch harry potter
enfin voila moi je suis un peu je suis
un petit peu de tout du fantastique de
la sf moi j'aime bien un petit peu je
suis éclectique
tout comme je réponds comme un dit mon
compère moi c'est plus le comics parce
que bon moi je suis un ça se voit pas
mais je suis plus vieux que monsieur et
est en fait moi j'ai commencé les comics
dans les années 80 et à l'époque trouvé
du comics en france c'est super galère
et avoir connu d'abord transmis ma
passion que ce soit mon cas mon collègue
ou mes enfants c'est super cool mais
ouais c'est comique jeux de rôles jeux
vidéo jusqu'à ce le tatoué
sais pas si on va le voir mais je tiens
ici mon petit jeu qui requerra que j'ai
dit à mon batman qui est là aussi ce qui
est un très dark un d'ailleurs bah ça
c'est la version sa version de deux
amours de duke week s'est pas fait parce
que là non pour moi the best ever au
niveau des scénarios de lyon s'est passé
on avait effectivement un festival geek
comme ça dans les yvelines ça manquait
justement c'est pour ça que vous avez eu
envie de leur organiser je rappelle ce
sera 21 22 mai pour ceux qui suivent
leur diffusion de cette émission bar à
thé ou alors vous y avaient participé
mais en tout cas il n'aura sans doute et
on l'espère d'autres éditions mais ça
manquait ce rendez vous à cette échelle
là où c'est à cette échelle là on a
plein de petites initiatives qui ont été
lancés notamment par des municipalités
on pense aux plaisirs gaming show qui a
eu lieu et rien pas longtemps
saint cyr l'école fait aussi pas mal de
trucs sur le jeu de plateau drôle mais
c'est avec un truc qui regroupe autant
de thématiques
à cette échelle là avec des invités
voilà des intervenants des initiations
ce n'était pas quelque chose qui avait
qui a été fait en fait pour le moment
dans 78 donc on s'est dit pas pourquoi
on ne serait obligé constamment aller en
région parisienne alors qu'on peut faire
ça chez nous tranquillement dans notre
jolie verdure on sera beaucoup mais au
parc de diane que dans les transports en
commun parisiens et puis voilà le truc
je rebondis sur ce qui vient dire c'est
que l' avantage on est en plein air et
non qui ça veut dire que les gens qui ne
supportent pas d'être enfermé dans un
truc qu'il ya de l'eau par exemple on
prend par exemple la japan expo où paris
manga ou s'est vraiment concentré oui on
en parle on en pense exactement chers
amis mais voilà le truc qui se passe
c'est que simplement on veut faire un
truc c'est surtout qu'on peut fermer aux
jeunes qu'ils peuvent pas se déplacer ou
qui pour eux c'est trop cher de faire un
truc assez abordable totalement
abordable au niveau des prix ils sont
combien pour le réhabiliter euros
l'entrée à 8 euros l'entrée ça c'est ce
qu'ont pays il ya 20 ans à la japan expo
c'est familial surtout que on a on a
voulu mettre plusieurs univers dedans
pour que toute la famille se retrouve là
dedans par exemple si on a le papa qui
est intéressé par tout ce qui est
historique on a ce qu'il faut on va
avoir marché ligue 1 on va avoir un
village médiéval en plein milieu du
salon donc voilà il ya déjà ça le
l'aspect historique et là dedans il y en
a pourtant justement programmation
parler de ce marché médiéval d'autres
animations rendez vous il ya des guests
et wiggins oui on peut en parler des
gains de roter poussé au la voix
française de margot robbie qui joue
harley quinn l'analogie et qui est
mortelle à dell pour les enfants là et
c'est la voix aussi de disney channel on
voit les prairies connu la paix n'est
pas quelques 10 mai
basile au bo zagnanado relais s'applique
ici voilà alexandrie qui la voit donc de
elijah wood danseurs des anneaux frodon
chris evans captain america et bien
d'autres aussi derrière flash la série
de flash et du coup bastien bourrelets
qui lui plus dans le doublage de
d'animation mangas donc qu'il a fait et
reiniger dans l'attaqué des titans il à
cessieu madoff doit il a fait avec ce
que j dis on va lâcher genus de one
touch mouse et moss chez nous il est
aussi mort oui effectivement qui est en
fait faut savoir que dans ce manga là en
français c'est orelsan qui fait la voix
du héros oui c'est vrai donc ça fait
intéressant d'avoir un point de vue
différent commençons par
bus et des invités vous l'avez compris
lors de ce festival des rendez-vous des
exposants aussi et puis on pourra
s'initier au quidditch forcément le
monde d'harry potter est bien présent
c'est ça le président du club qui est
l'art jours il a accueilli justement
alors d'un petit entraînement avec son
équipe de quidditch reportage
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais enfourché mon balai
pour vous présenter l'équipe des aides
l'essonne qui est basée ici aux quais
sous bois
[Musique]
pour nous présenter ce sport insolite je
suis aux côtés de gilles qui est père
fondateur qui est également coach joueur
qui fait un peu tout ici alors gilles
qu'est ce que c'est ce sport alors le
quidditch et en fait c'est un patchwork
de différents sports on a le rugby pour
les contacter on a le handball pour la
forme du tir on a le cardio beaucoup de
cardio parce qu'il faut savoir que le
terrain qui est derrière nous fait quand
même 44 mètres de long pour 3 de large
donc ce qui est assez long et on peut
aller marquer que derrière comme devant
au niveau des buts et on a aussi le
ballon prisonnier donc le dodgeball donc
on a des ballons de football qu'on se
tire royalement dessus donc sert là
c'est un sport de tout ça c'est un
mélange de ça et ça port mixte on le
voit derrière il n'y a pas de balle et
un ses
bâtons quels sont les autres différences
avec la saga harry potter et ce sport
qui est devenu un vrai sport oui c'est
devenu un vrai sport en fait il ya une
coupe de france et une coupe d'europe ya
une coupe d'europe des nations il ya une
coupe du monde que les etats-unis ont
gagné contre la belgique en italie avant
de co lead donc là il ya une nouvelle
qui devrait arriver donc la france est
sélectionné donc elle va y aller aussi
donc cocorico ben oui bah en fait tout
est différent le ballet on ne vole pas
on court avec les ballons de deux boules
les ballons de les cogneurs les c'est
devenu des ballons de football le soin
fait un ballon de volley dégonfler qu'on
peut tenir une main et en fait c'est une
sorte de contrainte d'avoir le ballet
parce qu'il faut toujours avoir une main
dessus ou d'avoir toujours entre les
jambes si on l'a pas on est obligé de
toucher ses cages il ya également le vif
d'or je crois qui apparaît en deuxième
partie de match si je peux dire
quasiment on va dire presque à la fin à
ce que ça arrive à la 18e minute donc à
partir de dix huitième minute on a donc
joueur qui vient avec le familles
soucieuses short jaune que j'ai là avec
une balle de tennis dans une chaussette
et le but c'est d'attraper le vif d'or
sans toucher le joueur donc c'est un peu
compliqué ils ont voulu tester aux états
unis avec un drone mais ça a pas fait
long feu le drone a été cassée
directement après ces explications sur
ce sport place à l'entraînement je vais
tester ces disciplines
[Musique]
là on est bon voilà la même si tu
t'écartes un peu c'est pas grave par
contre si vraiment tu commences à sortir
la déconsidérer tomber c'est comme si tu
étais touché par un cognard donc ballet
au dessus de la tête tu vas toucher
tebbutt après je crois bien pour monter
sur son balai et là c'est ok
[Musique]
ah oui c'est fini
j'ai testé j'approuve ce sport le
quidditch il y a environ 400 licenciés
enfoncé une quarantaine de clubs
maintenant c'est à vous d'essayer
le bordeaux lui va tellement bien mais
ce mobile chez vous nous avez rejoint en
plateau parle avec son tv 78 dans un
instant on va parler pokémon vous êtes
séduits par le quidditch indépendant qui
c'est vrai que ça paraît plus difficile
encore que dans le film puisque leur
ballet fait un peu tout bas parce qu'ils
tirent là j'ai la peau y aller quand
c'est plus contacts physiques qui sont
est de temps en temps alors que bon nous
c'est un peu peur maintenant des faits
sa blessure je pense quand même la
clavicule malheureusement ça arrive
fréquemment que laminé sané attention le
but ce n'est pas de se blesser et on
peut s'initier 17 ans lors du festival
big up qui se déroulera donc aux
clayes-sous-bois 21-22 mer on revient
sur la programmation un peu les moments
forts de ce festival qui se déroule sur
deux jours riel panel déjà au moment où
on va avoir le samedi on a le panel le
concours de costumes ou de cosplay qui
aura lieu le samedi individuel le
dimanche en groupe on a il va y avoir
des intervenants il ya pas mal de choses
qui m'ont mis en place et les
initiations donc le matin qui ont être
pour le coup dit l'après midi sera le
sabre laser
de sa brawn à l'école comme ses deux
sabres laser de 50 ans qui viennent nous
voir après on a beaucoup de choses qui
vont se faire il ya des tournois qui ont
sont organisées par des exposants et un
tournoi de peu de yu-gi-oh qui sera fait
le samedi le dimanche et un jeu qui va
être découvert qui s'appelle l'heure
sauf will voilà ça c'est des jeux de
cartes en amont les tombes de jeux de
rôles aussi avec du coup le dragon
ludique qui organise des initiations de
jeu de rôle et le standing car nati
souci qui vient faire découvrir son
univers transmédia est
je pense que c'est déjà ça déjà la
rareté de ce tournoi kawaga l'otan pour
les enfants large audience et une
culture qui se renouvelle sans cesse
c'est très basés dans les années 80-90
peut être même si harry potter est quand
même plus récents mais est-ce que ça une
culture qui se renouvelle sans cesse on
est tous basés sur ce qui s'est fait
avant de cette façon ils seraient
compliquées dréan voilà à monter peut
pas réinventer la poudre mais on peut
s'en inspirer faire des variantes l'abri
mais y aura des nouvelles licences aussi
à des minerais les choses qui peuvent
sortir ne m'a jamais on pense à moi je
pense à cela ce qu'a dit cui et de
l'avant ou manga qui sera chez nous
d'ailleurs la liste blanche entre les
légendes africaines et le style manga
qui a réussi à faire de l'animation avec
ça et moins partiellement j'aime
beaucoup le concept mais c'est vrai que
des noues des nouveautés c'est compliqué
d'en avoir mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'en fait même juste ré exploiter une
licence qui est social c'est toujours à
gré sans ciel essentiel c'est qui déjà
il faut trouver les gens trouvent leur
patient par exemple on prend un manga
qui a cartonné l'attaqué des titans et
qui a cartonné mais c'est parti sur des
anciens trucks ont tranché des bases de
goldorak avec à des golgoths des trucs
comme ça mais après s'il modifie en
natif et toujours et puis ce qui vient
nourrir aussi cette culture geek depuis
quelques temps tout de même c ces voix
française les voix de doublage qui
séduisent de plus en plus on a parlé de
dorit est poussé au tout à l'heure pour
ceux qui ne la connaissent pas un petit
extrait tout de même
oui alors quoi je dois tuer tout le
monde et il caffè
[Musique]
désolé
mais moi
sinon je rigole allaient elles n'ont pas
vraiment dit ça
doreto et poussé aulas voit donc
officiel de margot robbie notamment ou
encore josé tout à l'heure un van et
loupé dans les mondes de ralph
production disney la fausse idée voit
dans la princesse et la grenouille de
disney aussi fait plus plusieurs et
leurs biens la dernière en date c'est
mortel adel sont mortes et la belgique
toile effectivement donné sa voix et
vous pourrez la rencontrer lors du
festival merci à tous les deux les
détails sur guy cup festival point fr
pour toute la programmation merci encore
et je viens on va pouvoir lors du
week-end ce sera à suivre ensuite sur
sur l'antenne de tv soixante dix huit
pour le résumer réclusion bixente vous
allez nous parler d'une franchise
franchise par donc on connaît bien celle
des pokémon né dans les années 90 figure
emblématique ce petit piquey tueur ait
fait ça sera une petite souris
électrique je me suis penché plus
particulièrement sur un jeu qui a
littéralement balayé l'été 2016 le
principe je crois que beaucoup le
connaissent on a son téléphone on marche
jusqu'à croiser un pokémon dans la rue
puis il faut le capturer avec ses
pokéball on a tous vu des gens comme ça
dans la rue tourner le dos à faire ce
petit mouvement voilà je crois que ça
parle de ça parle bien pauvre en buts
c'est un peu le précurseur d'un nouveau
concept sortira et jouer à la fois
voilà de 2016 temps exactement c'est pas
tout neuf mais on y joue encore oui
figurez vous qu on y joue encore une
communité d'irréductibles dresseur
continue d'arpenter les rues à la
recherche des petites créatures de la
licence qu'on ne présente plus la preuve
autour du centre commercial de vélizy 2
où j'ai pu rencontrer certains d'un
événement récent regardez il ya certes
de moins en moins mais il ya toujours
des vrais joueurs des mêmes des très
forts qui joue qui sortent c'est sympa
ils ont même réussi à faire survivre le
jeu alors qu'il y avait un confinement
il serait votre effort pokémon gauche un
jeu auquel je joue assez fréquemment
depuis quelques semaines à peine j'avais
commencé au tout début du jeu et j'ai
repris il ya quelques semaines pour
parce que j'aime beaucoup pokémon de
base depuis tout petit pokémon premières
versions pokémon bleu reçu à noël quand
j'étais tout petit à 5 ans et j'ai
continué à jouer achète chaque jeu là
dix ans chaque année j'ai passé un super
moment à me balader autour du centre
sont commerciales et puis être avec des
gens que je connais pas à discuter
échanger enfin là c'est un bon moment
donné on veut dire vous avez comme le
dernier joueur certains viennent même de
picardie viennent de loin pour justement
découvrir encore avec des créatures il y
en a pleins ils sont très motivés quoi
vous voyez c'est dire si le jeu attire
encore son public mais s'il était là ce
n'est pas par hasard c'est pour un
événement il fallait capturer un nouveau
pokémon dans le jeu nounours on sait des
journées spéciales exactement tous les
mois organisé par une antique les
créateurs de pokémon go ça s'appelle un
community des étaient présents pour
rassembler les joueurs et animer un peu
le jeu l'après-midi un youtube et
reconnue dans le milieu de pokémon new
titeuf il vous présentera la journée
mieux que moi écouter un pokémon qui
apparaît en masse sur le jeu sur
l'application et on a des chances de la
voir dans une couleur différente c'est à
dire de l'avoir en shining chromatique
en français on dit ça et du coup là à
vélizy 2 il ya plus de pokerstop plus de
pokémon qui pape et et puis des petits
bonus pour les joueurs qui sont qui sont
dans le coin donc voilà ce petit nous
lançons ce petit nounours rose ou jaune
ça dépend si on a de la chance on non je
n'ai pas compté mais en tout cas il y
avait énormément de noms peut-être une
centaine de personnes en orbite au temps
du centre avec le téléphone sortie des
accessoires en tout genre tee-shirts
casquettes sacs à dos je me casse voilà
la casquette pikachu on la reconnaît
petite cerise sur le gâteau ce jour-là
un partenariat avec eco zia en fait tous
les 5 km marche et parent or ni antix
engagé à planter un arbre une activité
donc ludique écolo de partage c'est
aussi ça le jeu vidéo aujourd'hui voilà
c'est plus uniquement dans son salon à
derrière sa console et son écran bixente
vous restez avec nous on va parler
justement de jeux vidéo ou encore de
retrogaming plus précisément bonjour à
notre un nouvel invité bonjour vous 13,6
pc long de votre entreprise dédiée au
retrogaming sébastien est vous êtes le
président fondateur donc de cette
entreprise basée notamment sur saint
quentin en yvelines événementiel bat
spécialisé dans le jeu vidéo c'est à
dire que vous organisez des événements
autour du retrogaming n'avait pas une
boutique de jeux vidéo voyons tout à
fait je ne suis pas commerçant je suis
prestataire événementiel donc je me
déplace sur le site de mes clients qui
viennent de secteurs d'activité très
variés donc ça peut être aussi bien des
salons grand public des grands
événements sportifs et beaucoup
d'événements d'entreprise pour animer
des séminaires et team building des
expos aussi avec le désir peut être est
ce que vous avez mais j'ai un projet
notamment avec le muy med l'occasion de
parler 2024 voilà j'ai cette idée un peu
folle de proposer une exposition sur
l'histoire des jeux olympiques dans le
jeu vidéo avec bien sûr une des
activités vidéoludiques du jeu parce
qu'une fois qu'on a redécouvert les
consoles les jeux on a envie de les
toucher on a envie de jouer avec et
voilà dans tous les cas de partager ce
plaisir avec le plus grand nombre à
l'occasion de paris 2024 donc le musée
de la ville qui pourrait proposer cette
animation c'est une passion pour vous
j'imagine le créneau années 80-90 jeu
vidéo oui moi c'est une vraie madeleine
de proust d'un alors moi j'ai une
première carrière dans l'événementiel
sportif en parallèle une passion pour le
jeu vidéo rétro je pas un gros gamer
mais je suis un collectionneur moi ce
que j'aime c'est l'objet c'est raconter
des histoires et il ya deux ans j'ai
assemblé ces deux expertises on va dire
pour créer reset xp
me lancer de manière professionnelle sur
le secteur qui est aujourd'hui en fait
pour moi une niche mais je suis le
premier à l'investir de manière encore
une fois encadrés par une par une
société et les le début d'activité
plutôt plutôt bon et comment on passe
justement de la passion véritablement à
la profession étiez plutôt sur le tennis
à la base un effectivement fait que
davis met en avant une dizaine d'années
organisateurs des rencontres de coupe
davis et de fed cup pour la fédération
française de tennis donc on va dire une
petite expérience dans le secteur de
l'événementiel et puis ben voilà en fait
je jeu mais cette expérience passée au
service de ma passion personnelle et
j'utilise les mêmes ingrédients en
termes de scénographie d'organisation
logistique pour proposer des animations
donc qui use je ne me fixe pas de
limites puisque voilà dans
l'événementiel à partir du moment où on
a des moyens on a du matériel on a les
experts on peut déployer des des
événements importants donc pour
l'instant je maîtrise tout de a à z mais
j'espère bien embarquée du monde avec
moi sur des sur des grosses
manifestations vous parlez de madeleine
de proust les jeux vidéos qui sont ces
madeleines de proust un petit peu
quelques titres pour moi pour moi voilà
c'est noël 1980 avec pong voilà
le jeu mythique en noir et blanc avec
les voilà les deux barils le pixel qui a
qui représente la balle ensuite ensuite
c'est et 89 avec la première game boy
donc la première une des premières
consoles portables et puis le jeu tetris
et puis je me suis arrêté à la
playstation 1 donc une milieu des années
90 avec des petites comme tomb raider
final fantasy 7 voilà donc et après
après la vie professionnelle la vie de
famille vie après y avoir un petit peu
moins je vous confirme qu'ils ont des
concerts jeux vidéo aujourd'hui est
vraiment enfin voilà oui démocrate
américaine
ça vous parle ces titres de jeu et ses
jeux plus anciens je le montre la table
parce qu'il en a aussi quelques uns ces
vieilles boîtes on parle de support
matériel dématérialisée n'existait pas
encore à l'époque car c'est vrai que
pour moi j'ai déjà vu des images après
les jeux je considère comme rétro
aujourd'hui ils sont pas considérés trop
dans le monde du rétro gaming c'est la
wii tout ce qui est exposé thank you ou
encore sait pas encore mais ça commence
à faire son temps quand même ceci ceci
étant si je vous dis vectrex ça vous
parle pas ça non ça c'est ma madeleine
de proust à moi
c'était victoria c'était un peu
différent a lâché
1,78 très bien ici et là je prendrai
quand on demande un coup là c'est pas
mal on vous a reçus enfin plutôt vous
nous avez reçu chez vous on est allé
vous voir parce que on a voulu faire un
petit défi chaque mois dans cette
émission se lancent des défis au sein de
la rédaction bixente oui c'est vrai que
j'ai des filles mathilde sur sur
plusieurs jeux que vous nous avez
proposé
voilà c'était on a découvert un peu
votre univers il y avait énormément de
jeu mais on n'a pas de plus tout essai
on en est c'est 2 3 c'était déjà pas mal
regardez
et
aujourd'hui tv 60,18 vous emmène à la
découverte de risa 6 créé une société
événementielle spécialisée dans le rétro
gaming et du coup ça va être l'occasion
pour nous de tenter de te d'été ça va
être aussi un autre défi de la rédaction
entre journalistes d'alors part pas
favorite mais bon on va tout donner un
verrat je pense qu'on était tous les
deux trop jeunes pour certains jeux qui
me dit qu'on va essayer aujourd'hui mais
du coup avant d'ajuster découvrir un peu
plus ce que fait le retrogaming
[Musique]
m
le retro gaming c'est le plaisir de
jouer à des jeux vidéo anciens donc les
tout premiers jeux vidéo les années 80
les années 90 les grands classiques
comme pacman space invaders tetris c'est
vraiment le l'effet nostalgie madeleine
de proust qui qui fonctionne à plein
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mathilde bixente je vais vous faire
goûter aux sports électroniques rétro le
retro gaming esport expérience donc avec
un défi sur tetris vous allez devoir
faire le meilleur score et puis le
second défi ce sera sur space invaders
ou là il faudrait être le ou la plus
rapide pour terminer le premier niveau
[Musique]
comment s en sort là c'est maintient
pour l'instant
ils se bagarrent ce maillard
un début assez assez difficile
la mesure de la vitesse de descente des
pièces du big three
déjà s'incline complété
pas si mal
à la tête
bon très très dur vicente
[Musique]
on a eu pas mal de grandes barres
droites ça m'aide pour m'organiser
thabo ligne de me battre
auxerre
[Musique]
est jeune et il est pas mal on a
approché de l'année seuil est atteint
[Musique]
nos talons très proches en termes de
temps karima béton
comment est ce qu'on peut faire pour se
départager bon écoute et habite shalit
et mathilde je vous propose de vous
départager par un quiz
donc il y en a plusieurs qui vous sont
proposés mais vu votre
jeune âge je vous propose les années 90
ok on va être réparé fait aller
[Musique]
mais ni moi
et bien voilà le défi terminé du coup je
rentre je connais ma défaite était une
adversaire redoutable certaines stèles
je sais pas c'était serré s'est affairé
à une question prépare des noms c'est
mathilde qui s'est détaché après un peu
le bruit et donc j'ai le plaisir de lui
offrir ses petits goodies merci
vainqueur de l'épreuve merci city ce
maillot avec l'étoile chance et pas
comme l'autre consolation un bloc
efficace je pourrais écrire les
questions du coup dessus et guessoum
lankais j'ai échoué voilà pour revenir
plus fort réviser pour la prochaine fois
en tout cas merci beaucoup c'est bassin
nous avoir reçu un bel accueil à très
bientôt
bixente battu
mais mathis s'est très bien défendu
j'assume totalement ce genre d'animation
justement séduit de plus en plus pour
faire justement dans les entreprises du
team building des choses comme ça c'est
là notre produit phare et qui a même été
repérés par les acteurs de l'e sport je
prends du vrai sport donc cette ce
dispositif ce concept le retro gaming
ispoure expérience en fait qu'est le
sport électronique pour les plus de 25
ans plus de 30 ans dans le coup avec des
jeux qui sont faciles à prendre en main
un plaisir de jouer immédiat et puis on
peut très rapidement
au sein d'un événement d'entreprise que
qui conçoit avec un alternat de 20 ans
ou une drh de 55-60 ans offert la même
compétition donc compétition conviviale
bien sûr mais en tous les cas se
confronter les uns aux autres et passer
un bon un bon moment sans mais convivial
parce que l'édition de jeux vidéo des
fois ça fait un peu mal tourné quand
même on peut se faire chambrer ensuite
ça fait partie du sport 200 consoles 30
bornes d'arcade 3451 je sais les
chiffres que j'ai ça augmente et encore
ça augmente et oui avec une borne xbox
360 que j'ai acheté pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière puisque je suis sur la
route de clairefontaine pour y présenter
le retro gaming football expérience et
la fff a signé un contrat avec xbox donc
on met à dispo dès des consoles voilà
deux du tout début des années 2000 vous
chercher en permanence des des
nouveautés en tout cas d agrandir cette
collection alors de moins en moins je
cible plus les achats puisque en fait
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer je ne
propose pas les 200 consoles et 3000 jeu
enfin pas encore en tous les cas sur un
seul événement donc donc voilà je me
concentre vraiment sur les grands
classiques je sais que je vais tout les
constats une dizaine quinzaine de jeux
qui reviennent systématiquement qui sont
connues de tout le monde où on peut
vraiment s'amuser tout de suite et
pareil pour les consoles donc meachem la
france se console wii lancée d'un jeu
multijoueur des choses comme ça et pas
forcément dans ces louanges de drôles de
deux heures de jeu c'est pas le but
limité dans les années et elle est en
général d'assa s'appelait bien ça
s'arrête dans le rétro game justement
quel il ya une date alors les libéraux
disent les puristes s'arrête à la
cartouche dès qu'on est passé au cd
pour eux c'est déjà très très moderne
moi je suis pas un puriste parce que là
où il ya 15 ans la playstation 2 à 20
enfin bon enfin les banques voilà le jus
pays est en fait chaque il ya un effet
glissant donc chaque génération tout le
monde a sa petite histoire avec le jeu
vidéo tout le monde a démarré avec une
première console et le but c'est de
proposer un panel de deux consoles qui
va parler un peu à tout le monde à
toutes les générations reset xp points
comme c'est le nom du site internet vous
avez toutes les infos vous pouvez
rentrer en contact avec sébastien aide
qui nous a donc accueilli pour ce défi
et qui venu en plateau elle nous
présentait avec ses lunettes bien sûr
quelques quelques jeux et sa collection
et son travail merci beaucoup d'être
venu merci également à bixente c'est la
fin à la fin de cette suite ce tour sur
télé 78 on va y arriver on se retrouve
bientôt sur notre antenne
[Musique]